liebe demokraten wir schauen dieser tage
an der politik beim scheitern zu der
nicht wenige genau dieses scheitern
prophezeit haben das war nicht nur wir
wenn man ein gebäude auf ein poröses
fundament setzt ist der gesamte bau
nichts wert ein solches großes fundament
ist der sogenannte flüchtling stil der
bundeskanzlerin mit herbert war
wir haben von anfang an gesagt dass die
bundesrepublik sich mit diesem handel
ablesbar macht und nun ist es soweit
allmählich dürfte auch der letzte
begriffen haben dass der türkische
präsident eben kein seriöser partner ist
die türkei führt in syrien einen
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg der
bundesaußenminister hat im oktober die
türkische offensive verurteilt am 28
februar aber verurteilte herr maas die
zitat fortgesetzten angriffe des
syrischen regimes und sprach der türkei
sein mitgefühl aus ja der start des
herrn assad ist ein regime aber ein land
aufzufordern es möge damit aufhören sein
eigenes territorium zu verteidigen das
ist es die provinz idlib ist syrisches
staatsgebiet mich türkisch ist mit
seinem tweet gestand der
bundesaußenminister der türkei am passau
das recht zu mit ihren truppen in syrien
zu stehen
ähnlich äußerte sich auch
regierungssprecher steffen seibert und
das grüne spricht der außenminister
einen aggressor sein mitgefühl aus diese
anbieter rey zeigt wie ablesbar wir
durch den flüchtling stil geworden sind
fans und focus konzerns
herr erdogan hat jetzt noch die stirn
die nato um unterstützung bei seinem
syrien abenteuer zu bitten das würde
bedeuten die nato in einen krieg mit
russland zu ziehen
der eu chefdiplomat herr borel warnt vor
dem zitat risiko in einen offenen großen
militärischen konflikt zu rutschen
zitat ende gottlob werden die amerikaner
bei diesem unsinn nicht mitspielen
die scheidende cdu vorsitzende und ein
kandidat für die nachfolge herr röttgen
fordern wegen putins unterstützung von
assad weitere sanktionen gegen russland
warum eigentliche röcken nicht gegen die
türkei russland wurde wegen der annexion
decken sanktioniert aber die türkei wird
von der bundesregierung nicht einmal
aufgefordert sich aus syrien
zurückzuziehen
erdogans drohung mit einer
migrantenwelle wirkt also vielleicht
nimmt sich die bundesregierung ein
beispiel mal am österreichischen
bundeskanzler sebastian kurz hat
griechenland unterstützung bei der
sicherung der eu außengrenzen angeboten
die krise so kurz sei durch werbung
bewusst ausgelöst worden der
zehntausende menschen in bussen unter
falschen versprechungen an die grenze
transportiert habe kurz sprach von einem
organisierten ansturm und nannte das
verhalten der türkischen seite einen
angriff auf die eu
der türkische präsident missbrauche die
migranten als waffe und als druckmittel
dieses vorgehen verurteile aufs
schärfste
warum eigentlich dagegen keine
sanktionen bei den migranten handelt
sich übrigens nur in ausnahmefällen um
syrer die aus dem umkämpften idlib
geflohen sind und auch sehr selten und
frauen und kinder auch wenn manche
medien etwas anderes suggerieren
im jahr 2015 die wirkliche humanitäre
hilfe muss direkt in die umkämpfte
region gehen
die bundeskanzlerin hat gesagt und wir
hören es von der cdu ununterbrochen 2015
dürfe sich nicht wiederholen
aber ich fürchte es fehlt der politische
wille dazu wenn sich 2015 nicht
wiederholen soll gibt es nur einen weg
wir müssen endlich unsere grenzen gegen
illegale migration schützen und wenn die
europäischen außengrenzen nicht zu
schützen sind dann müssen wir die
deutschen grenzen schützen
die bundeskanzlerin hat im september
2002 im bundestag gesagt bei der
einwanderung sei das maß des zumutbaren
überschritten
bevor wir neue zuwanderung haben müssen
wir erst einmal die integration
verbessern zitat unserer bundeskanzlerin
das ist exakt die position der afg
nunmehr zwei mehr als zwei millionen
migranten später sollte die
bundeskanzlerin ihren worten endlich
taten folgen lassen ich bin da gerade
alexander gauland war dass der
fraktionsvorsitzende der fw fraktion
[Applaus]